people say my dad looks like the food
critic from ratatouille
i don't look like this guy well we're
gonna be transforming you into him today
no no no no no no all right let's get
into some proper clothes
i gotta change it all right now let's
slick the hair back
i hate this beautiful don't touch me
time for makeup absolutely beautiful now
put the glasses on
we don't need the glass final reveal
oh my gosh do the face i don't want to
do this please do the face
hey dad since everybody loved that
ratatouille skit so much no no no no no
that was a one time thing
absolutely yes you look great
and you know what if i got to do this
you're going to do the part of alfredo
linguini
nah dude i don't want to i hate this
and now is scene from ratatouille
my compliments to the chef
a lot of you say that my dad looks like
the dad from coralline
no way whether he thinks so we're not
we're gonna be making you look like him
today
this time i'm putting my foot down
absolutely no first let's get you into a
green shirt
perfect it doesn't say michigan state
all right we gotta do something with
this hair don't ever touch me again
beautiful look at this what part about
don't touch me didn't you understand
time for the eye makeup no
here we go oh my goodness
look at you you're beautiful i think i'm
going to move out
dad what kind of tic toc do you want to
do today i don't know
i could say coffee again people love my
new york accent now we we've done that
so many times what about another
ratatouille skit
yeah we did that already wait
wait are you are you thinking uh-huh how
about we make a video where we're both
brainstorming and in the end we both
come up with the same idea
and we'll save that idea at the exact
same time to add comedic effect
and we'll do it in several clips because
we're not talented enough to do it in
one
and let's add our secret handshake at
the end
[Applause]
squirt squirt squirt squirt
dab there's a tick tock trend where you
put an egg under a container and we take
turns going back
i know i know i've seen it you don't
have to tell me i know you know how this
works i know how it works watch
why did you do that try this again what
is that oh if we break another egg i'd
rather eat it that's not how it works
what is this well i told you i'm not
wasting any pressure saying that's not
how the game works
is this a real egg this time why
why
i'm done i'm done no we're done now
we're done we're done we're done
my dad's really pissed off because i
spent 22 dollars at the tick-tock apple
juice
22 for this look look at the size of
this thing compared to this
three dollars 22 dollars
bite into it just buy it why do you want
me to bite into it it sounds like an
apple
how does that thing sound like an apple
dude just try it leave me alone
dad just take you're drinking it that
little sip was eight dollars worth no
come on just take a bite out of it
all right all right all right all right
right do you see we gotta get more
frank that's too expensive it's only 22
karen
you